is the media deliberately scaring people
about North Korea our Republicans really
willing to cancel the 20/20 election and
we're about to have on the famous
infamous most important guy in America
today
James d'amour the Google memo guy in
just a second i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
okay we're all waiting with bated breath
to talk to James Moore he's sitting
right here on the Skype so let me
talking to him momentarily we just want
to jump right into it because I know
that our audience has been waiting with
bated breath ever since I announced this
morning on Twitter that we would be
having on the author of the Google memo
the infamous Google memo the most
important document since the Magna Carta
James d'amour is joining us right now he
of course is a senior engineer at Google
until he made the mistake of pending and
eminently correct scientific treatise on
the differences between men and women
and why that may contribute in part to
discrepancies in terms of the levels of
employment and wages at Google between
women and men and then of course Google
found out about his wrong thing and he
was fired James thanks so much for
joining the program yeah going for okay
so let me just jump right in here and I
want to ask you began to start you've
alleged that there's actually some
illegal activity going on at Google
because that's why presumably that you
should be in trouble for firing you
because it's an out well state
California is now well state anybody can
be fired for anybody any reason but
according to the National Labor
Relations Board you cannot be fired if
you're whistleblowing so what is the
purported illegal activity that's going
on at Google that you are attempting to
expose so part of it is that they treat
people differently in the hiring process
depending on what their race or gender
is and some teams will preferentially
choose certain groups
okay so you've also said that they have
these sort of super-secret diversity
sessions in which they discuss all of
this can you take us inside one of those
what does that look like from the inside
it's just a group of always people
talking about the benefits of diversity
and how much they love diversity and all
the sexism and racism that happens and
how we have to try to fix that okay we
know that Google has spent some two
hundred and sixty five million dollars
apparently trying to increase their
diversity ratios and this of course has
been a wild fail well I've read your
memo at least three times now because I
just want to make sure I'm not crazy
because if you watch the media coverage
of your memo it is not in any way
related to the actual content of the
memo the media's made a bunch of
different claims about the memo they've
said that you were saying
in the memo that women are biologically
unfit for tech that was a Chiron on CNN
were you making the claim James d'amore
Google memo guy were you making the
claim that women are biologically unfit
for the tech industry no I was just
trying to explain why we see a disparity
in the population of people that are
interested in working in tech and begin
and you can see that right there I mean
I'm quoting your memo back to you here
but it says I'm not saying that all men
differ from all women in the following
ways that these differences are just I'm
simply stating that the distribution of
preferences and abilities of men and
women women differ in part due to
biological causes this has been
translated by the left into you are
saying that women ought not work in tech
or they're unqualified for tech you
weren't even saying you have an entire
section of your memo promoting the idea
that there should be more women in tech
and you offered a bunch of ways that you
think that the tech community could be
made more welcoming to women so are you
in favor of more women right yeah I mean
I like women right so and if we're in
general just trying to get more people
interested in tech then that would be
one way to do it so I want to I want to
talk to you a little bit about something
that the YouTube CEO woman in Susan
watch kicky that she wrote this morning
over at Forbes she wrote a piece at
Forbes at the horrors of your memo and
how they obviously emotionally crippled
her a young daughter who apparently came
up to her and said mom is it true that
there are biological reasons why there
are fewer women in tech and leadership
now it seems to me that that was not
exactly the claim you were making is it
true there are biological reasons why
there are fewer women in tech and
leadership what's your response to the
YouTube CEO well I mean to me we could
tell what Piers Morgan was trying to do
to you on his show by taking a little
kid out and saying oh aren't you sorry
for him right I mean they're just trying
to guilt me so I do want to get that one
friend yeah I do want to ask you about
what the what the political
representation is like inside Google
because there was a poll sort of an
informal poll that came out this morning
that said that 56% of people who were
responding to this online poll who are
working at Google said that they were
against your firing number one you know
are there a lot of people inside Google
who have been expressing support for you
yes since I've
wrote it there have been many people
that privately messaged me and said yeah
I support you I agree this is a real
problem do you think that Google is
biasing their search results in the way
they do business toward the left do you
think that how they're treating you is
reflective of how they do business as a
company I don't know about biasing
search results but they may definitely
be biasing who they do business with
okay so uh and inside the company itself
is it do you think that there is a
obvious political preference for you
know folks on the left you know if you
had written a memo about how black lives
matter was the cause of the day and that
really mattered more than anything else
I mean they're all these sort of
internal Google chats apparently that
you're a part of these Google message
boards have you ever seen stuff like
that politically oriented material
toward the left and has that ever been a
problem for anyone yeah so you can
openly shame white people or all men and
we do this in our company-wide meeting
so yes there's definitely a bias towards
certain movements we had a whole TGIF
that was for the black lives matter
movement and in can you me some example
mutate you have company-wide meetings
where people are shamed
what does that what does that sound like
I can give me an example of some stuff
that people have said so I mean one
example was just that someone wrote a
question and then it had something to do
with gender she was a woman and out of
300 votes fifty of them were downloaded
and she was complaining about how she
didn't feel included at Google because
she got one six of them downloads and I
don't there were many other just random
examples okay so you know with with all
of this said number one you know I think
you have a lot of broad public support
obviously but it what do you think this
says about the left's views of science
because there's an article in Slate for
example today saying science is bad now
we we've now found that science is bad
Susan watch kick as I say she said at
the very end of her of her screed she
said that that these are questions that
shouldn't even be asked is a direct
quote from her piece at Forbes today she
said for example for instance what if we
replace the word women in
with another group what if the memo said
that biological differences amongst
black Hispanic or LGBTQ employees
explained their under-representation and
tech and leadership roles which some
people still be discussing the merit of
the memos arguments or there be a
universal call for swift action against
its author what do you make of the left
essentially saying that questions can
never be asked about topics where the
answer may not favor what the Left
wishes it to say yet they're at least
putting their ideology before truth in
these cases and she's just trying to
guilt me by association with like Nazis
or something and you know when one group
is just trying to guilt you and call you
names and the other is actually using
evidence in science you really know
which side is actually seeking truth and
this I think is one of the points that
that is why this story has captured the
imagination is because the memo itself
is really moderate in tone and tenor
even people like Kirsten powers who are
on the Left have said they really don't
see what the what the big problem here
is or why people are going nuts over it
and yet you step out of line at a
company like Google and the reason
people are freaked out about this is
obviously Google is a super powerful
company but this happens inside
Hollywood all the time this happens
inside journalistic institutions all the
time obviously so Jim's d'amore Google
metal guy what comes next for you I've
offered you off the air I offered you a
problem this gig to write about stem
issues particularly with regard to two
differences between men and women and
social science data and all of us but I
assume that you have job offers that are
coming in from a wide variety of sources
what comes what comes next for you now
that Google is no longer in your future
I'm still evaluating all my options it's
been a really busy pursuit and and I've
heard also that you were offered a
position by WikiLeaks out urge you not
to take them I think that is probably a
bad career move but it's up to you
you're free man and so I say well thank
you for for you know writing this memo
because I think obviously when more
truth is promulgated it's a better
country and and please keep us updated
as far as your own lawsuit or is that
actually going to happen or is that just
a possibility at this point of lawsuit
against Google yet it's a possibility
I'm definitely pursuing it
okay so keep us updated on that and
obviously we are rooting for for you as
far as the whistleblowing aspect of this
and please keep writing through things
even though there's pretty tremendous
blowback thanks so much for joining the
show I really appreciate it all right
thank thanks as James d'amour he's the
senior engineer at Google who penned
that diversity memo that regarding why
we Google so changes practices if we
wants to attract more women actually and
he got shellacked for it by the left and
and fired from from Google for that
James to more senior engineer at Google
thanks so much okay so in other news I
want to talk about what's going on with
North Korea because obviously this
continues to unfold let's start with
Brian Williams so Brian Williams who
should not be a member of the media
after repeatedly lying about his own
past over and over and over Brian
Williams was on MSNBC last night where
he is so respected because the 10s NBC
and Brian Williams said that the reason
that the media are covering North Korea
in such insane terms is because it is
their job to scare people now before we
get to Brian Williams on this I do want
to say that I think that a lot of this
is overblown North Korea has been
pursuing nuclear weapons for a long time
they've had nuclear weapons for a long
time obviously it's not good if an ICBM
is capable of reaching the United States
but mutually assured destruction is
still a thing and kim jeong-hoon or his
successors they would be fooled the
absolute fools if they were to try and
attack the United States we would wipe
them off the face of the earth in no
time flat
I mean legitimately if they fired a nuke
at us they would be toast their country
would be a sea of glass within moments I
mean this is not even talking about the
USSR right now the fact is that even if
their missile hit here it would do you
know awful awful damage that would be
that'd be terrible but we would survive
it and then we would nuke the living
crap out of them and that would be the
end of that so mutually assured
destruction is still a thing South Korea
it's a little bit it's a little bit more
tenuous because North Korea has been
pursuing violent incidents against South
Korea for years and years and years and
years they sank a South Korean ship a
few years back they killed a member of
the the North Korean leaders family with
VX gas at nerve gas at like an airport
so if you're South Korea mutually
assured destruction actually doesn't do
the trick for you because you always
have to fear that there's gonna be a
conventional war under the umbrella of
the mutually assured
action with the North Koreans but for
the United States are we deeply worried
that they're going to destroy us no
we're not deeply worried they're going
to destroy us I'm not losing a lot of
sleep over the possibility that LA is
going to be destroyed even though we are
under the umbrella of the North Korean
nuclear missile I'm really like really I
think that a lot of this is is hyped to
the extreme but Brian wind says that the
media having to have a duty to hike this
to the extreme my job tonight actually
is to scare people to death on this
subject so the talk isn't as free as it
is about a preemptive or surgical
military strike okay why did their job
to scare people to death and this is the
problem with the media the media sees it
as their job to push you into a certain
position they see it as their job to
evoke a certain emotional response in
you and it's something that we ought to
keep in mind when we look at media
coverage of world events for many
members of the media it is not just
about covering the events that are
important to you it is about trying to
cover the events so as to evoke an
emotional response in a particular way
another example of this today on an
unrelated topic so there's a poll that
lefties are passing around from The
Washington Post that says 52 percent of
Republicans would support the
postponement of the 2020 election if
President Trump called for such a
postponement like shocking result over
half of Republicans would be fine with
postponing the 2020 election if Trump
claimed voter fraud and said that he
didn't want to hold it the polls showed
that 56% of Republicans would be fine
with postponing it of Congress were to
support Trump in that effort okay so
you're getting a lot of thing pieces
from the left speaking of the media
though pushing people to an emotional
response it's important to know how they
got this particular result this was a
push poll by The Washington Post first
it asked respondents if voter fraud was
real but then it asked them if they
thought that it occurred and if Trump
won the popular vote and then finally it
asked them if Trump said that it
occurred would they be in favor of
postponing the election sorry these good
results no they're not good results but
is it true more than half of Republicans
would be fine with postponing the 2020
election I highly highly doubt it also
important to recognize that these sort
of push polls exist from both sides you
know in 20 in 2016 there is a poll from
WPA research they found that two-thirds
of Democrats would take an
unconstitutional third Obama term over
Hillary Clinton opponent November 14
from the economists found that 39
percent of Democrats wish the
Constitution would be changed to that
purpose so a couple of lessons from
these things
first lesson is most people only like
the rules if they benefit them they only
like the elections every four years if
their guy's not in power but the more
important things the media attempt to
gain a particular headline and very
often they are they're attempting to to
get to that headline via the questions
they ask and you can see it even look in
the interviews that I do obviously when
I ask a question I'm expecting a
particular response from people when I
talked to James d'amour I'm questioning
him in a way that I think is important
but obviously the responses that he
gives are ones that I'm looking for
right I mean I'm not I'm not questioning
him as a feminist would who's looking
for a different response from from James
tomorrow yeah that's the way the media
works and so you should always take that
into account when you look at the
coverage of North Korea so the media
yesterday was going nuts over Trump's
apparently provocative threats fired in
the fury of the theory and the fire the
power the glory the fury fire power
glory huge emissaries bands diva right
they were going nuts over Trump's over
to the top language but the reality is
does any of that make a huge difference
in all of this not really
okay General James Madison out man talk
mattis came out yesterday and what he
said was quote the United States and our
allies have the demonstrated
capabilities and unquestionable
commitment to defend ourselves from an
attack kim jeong-hoon should take heed
of the UN Security Council's unified
voice and statements from government's
the world over who agree the DPRK that's
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
poses a threat to global security and
stability the DPRK must choose to stop
isolating itself and stand down its
pursuit of nuclear weapons the DPRK
should cease any considerations of
actions that would lead to the end of
its regime and the destruction of its
people that's pretty harsh language from
mattis but I don't see the media losing
their minds over that that I think is
last year a couple of years ago Barack
Obama threatens to destroy North Korea
so in the media obviously are attempting
to evoke fear in Americans that Trump's
precipitous nature will lead to a
nuclear exchange that's not what's going
to happen here it's not what's going to
happen here in North Korea is basically
they understand that they're in a
rhetorical pissing match now with Trump
and so there's a statement released by
the North Korean military in which they
basically called Trump a load of
nonsense they said that his threat was a
quote unquote load of nonsense and they
called him a guy the rest of reason so
you basically have Trump and the leader
of North Korea in a Twitter fight but is
this going to devolve into nuclear war I
really don't think so
No and here's the fact okay the fact is
that people who are living really under
the threat of North Korea are happy that
the United States is taking a pretty
militant position on all this Guam which
was a station that was threatened by
North Korea in response to Trump's
threat they the governor of Guam he he
likes from I mean here here he is
praising Trump so do you think that the
president's remarks are getting to the
heart of the problem no longer strategic
patience and does that play to solving
this problem in the big picture as far
as I'm concerned as an American citizen
I want a president that says that if any
nation such as North Korea attacks warm
attacks Honolulu attacks the west coast
that they will be met with hell and fury
what I'm concerned about is if a u.s.
senator says initiate an attack and
causing alarm and remembering that there
are they're in the Mariana Islands this
is American sovereign soil this is 600
mile archipelago violence similar to
Hawaii where there are over 200,000
American citizens Rio it's important
that as we make decisions that those
folks that are in a position of
leadership that they understand to that
war is the last option because not only
will tens of thousands American military
forces independence of be affected by a
regional war right but because of the
western Pacific has American soil in it
then a couple hundred thousand Americans
could get caught in the crosshairs so I
think it's important to be very strong
right at the same time be calm
and I think everybody is on board with
this and I don't think Trump is
precipitously into launching nuclear war
but I've got a lot of this is the
Democrats playing politics with all of
this a lot of this is the Democrat
attempting to play politics with with
national security and basically suggest
that Trump is a madman who is going to
get us into a nuclear war and MSNBC
military analysts essentially said this
he said if Trump ordered a nuclear
launch mattis would defy it because
obviously Trump is crazy he quit for
what if he orders a nuclear strike I
mean my understanding from general
Hayden and public comments is that
that's a pretty quick timeframe between
the command I'll tell you what mattis
would defy an order yeah I think you
would don't forget the people Wow yeah
he'd say I'm not going I'm not doing it
okay so this is it this is a narrative
the media is creating the Trump is a
nutcase and he's going to order a
nuclear launch for no apparent reason
again I've seen no evidence of this on
the on the international scale from from
president Trump the sort of precipitous
action even on domestic policy Trump
will fire off a tweet but the actions
that he's taking are really not
particularly precipitous the only
precipitous action that you can say the
Trump has really taken was his
transgender been in the military tweets
and even those are not being implemented
by the Pentagon because there was no
follow-up so you know the business of
American government does not work quite
as smoothly as people think now there's
this sort of old Cold War mentality that
were five seconds away from launching
nuclear war I don't think that's right
and I do think the media are attempting
to twist you into not make you feel
really uncomfortable make you feel like
we're a second away from being
obliterated you know we also don't know
what nuclear we all we also know
military options are on the table I mean
we don't I've been saying this now for
weeks okay I don't know as much as the
Department of Defense knows about what
military options are on the table to
take out the Kim regime but I promise
you that the last thing that anyone
wants including President Trump is a
nuclear exchange as President Trump said
during the campaign there's nothing like
nuclear nothing like it it's just the
biggest and the hugest you remember when
he actually said that during a debate
which is pretty incredible so now all of
that said don't be deeply worried don't
worry so much everything will be okay
you know
worried in the sense that we should come
up with solution to North Korea but
don't worry that we're five seconds away
from a nuclear exchange we're not okay
so before I go any further I want to
talk about Trump's conflicts with Mitch
McConnell I also really want to get to
some things I like things I hate and the
big idea today I really want to get to
the big idea because I think there's
some important stuff here well there is
a bit of a conflict breaking out now
between President Trump and Mitch
McConnell and that's not because Trump
and McConnell disagree on policy as much
as it is because Trump doesn't like when
people insult him and this is my biggest
problem with Trump attacking McConnell
if you want to attack McConnell on
policy I'm totally fine with that
McConnell has not been an effective
Senate Majority Leader thus far clearly
if you're just attacking McConnell
because you're mad at him then that's a
whole
different story you know it seems that
he's attacking mcconnell cuz he's mad at
him not on policy if you're really mad
at mcconnell on policy he wouldn't be
backing Luther strange in Alabama who's
sort of a moderate Republican who backs
McConnell's play over a couple of other
candidates like Roy Moore in Alabama so
what this really says to me is that
Trump is still being driven by personal
animus for particular political figures
not being driven by policy
considerations which is a problem right
I want to see the policy I don't care
about the personal animus I don't get
about Trump's personal issues I don't
either Trump likes McConnell that makes
no difference to me it makes a
difference to me whether we get the
policies that I would like to see and
that's what should make a difference to
you you shouldn't be upset if Trump is
mad at McConnell and McConnell's upset
of Trump who cares in the soap opera you
should be much more upset if you're not
getting the policies that were promised
to you
so Trump was ripping McConnell on
Twitter it all started because McConnell
stated on at some Rotary Club meeting
that Trump had excessive expectations of
what the Senate could do storyline is
that we have a dominant is because in
part the President and others have said
these early kind of lies about things
need to be done by a certain point our
new president of course I've been in a
lot of work before and I think had
excessive expectations about how quickly
things happened in the democratic
process and so part of the reason I
think people feel like we're honor
underperforming is because too many kind
of artificial deadlines on unrelated to
the reality of the complexity of
legislating may not have been fully
understood and of course our political
adversaries if he loves one thing he
done okay so McConnell is not totally
wrong on this and the fact is the
President Trump doesn't understand how
the vagaries of the Senate work and so
he's upset with it Trump but if the
Trump is right when he says this to
McConnell so he retweets back in
McConnell any tweets that he tweeted
senator Mitch McConnell said I had
excessive expectations but I don't think
so after seven years of hearing repeal
and replace why not done fair question
Trump should ask himself that because he
wasn't particularly active as we pointed
out at the time in pushing the thing
beyond the last couple of weeks
and didn't understand the policy but you
know that's not a wrong to man I would
hope that from personal animus for Mitch
McConnell turns into him actually
demanding policies that I like from
Mitch McConnell and McConnell caving
that's what I would like to see but it's
even Laura Ingraham is noting it's hard
for Trump to be ripping McConnell at the
same time he's providing McConnell with
more senators who agree with McConnell
president Trump came out and endorsed
Luther strange and that Alabama special
election for Jeff session for Jeff
Sessions seat now Luther strange was
appointed so he's the incumbent for the
time being there's all these other
people running including mo Brooks and
the judge Roy Moore is running and so
they're probably gonna have to have a
runoff because no one will get a
majority but Donald Trump came out and
endorsed the incumbent more of an
establishment a guy Luther strange and
that is very interesting because that's
Mitch McConnell's favorite pick right so
mobile is acknowledging this this is
obviously true so if Trump is going to
go after members of the Republican Party
let's do it on the basis of policy what
I don't want and what I sort of see
happening which is which is not
particularly encouraging to me is that
President Trump is mad at leaders of the
Republican Party and you could easily
see Chuck Schumer making an overture to
him after the 2018 election and from
swivelling left in order to work with
people who are praising him more Folsom
Lee and gaining praise from the New York
Times in the process that's the scary
part of all of this in terms of policy
okay I want to get two things I like in
things I hate in the big idea but before
we do all that you're going to have to
go over to Daley wire calm and subscribe
we bring you the greatest of content ok
$9.99 a month means that not only you
get to see this most watch to mode this
most listened to news and politics
podcast in the country according to
iTunes we're still number two to Oprah
people we're still number two to Oprah
Oprah the Linda asks you must be
defeated so go and leave review and
subscribe but not only do you get our
show when you when you subscribe for
$9.99 a month over at daily wire calm
you also get andrew Clavin show which is
searching up the iTunes charts you get
Michael Knowles a show live you get the
whole thing live I get to be part of
their mail bag and you get part of my
mailbag we're doing that tomorrow to get
all of that ed if you get the annual
subscription you get this the very
finest of tumblers leftist tears hot or
cold the tumbler incomparable
indescribable until you hold it in your
hands you will never be able to
understand the glories of it and all it
will cost you is $99 annual membership
comes along with all the other great
things I just told you about again if
you just want to listen later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud leave us a review
we definitely appreciate it
we are the the top news and politics
podcast in America
[Music]
you
okay so let's do some things I like and
some things I hate in the big idea so
Thursday's are our big idea day here at
the Ben Shapiro show so let's first
start with things I like so you know
we're talking about communism and I
thought that would be worthwhile to
recommend a book about North Korea in
case you are interested in what North
Korea is actually like today the book is
by Andre lank often it's called the real
North Korea life and politics in the
failed Stalinist utopia and it's a
fascinating book because it doesn't try
to paint an excessively dark picture of
North Korea while not ignoring the
problems in North Korea basically it
says that it is a stunted rump state
that is run what it is run in the most
horrific dictatorial way and that
manifests more in the everyday lives of
North Koreans then it even does in sort
of our horror imaginations of gulags and
people being shot and unmasked that's
what's happening then just the the
gradual degradation of a great people
and the real North Korea on dry land
cough fully worth reading I think a fair
and honest relatively objective look at
what North Korea is like today it is a
stain on the on the global on the so
called global community that doesn't
really exist it's a stain on the UN
certainly that North Korea has continued
to terrorizes people for more than half
a century at this point just as it
sustained on the international community
that Cuba continues to be a dictatorial
backwater it's really it's really quite
horrifying if there were a way to get
rid of the Kim regime I'm all for it
okay other things that I like so this
exchange is making the rounds on the on
the interwebs it is an amazing exchange
James Franco the actor was talking with
his Princeton professor and the issue of
abortion came up now his Princeton
professor her name is Elliot Michaelson
and she is discussing her support for
early stage abortion and why she
believes nothing morally bad happens
when it occurs and even James Franco
scenes are going what you're saying
makes no sense to me okay and James
Franco I cannot imagine is pro-life but
even he is looking at her and going this
doesn't make sense what you are saying
namely because what the left says with
regard to abortion doesn't make a whole
hell of a lot of moral sense here's a
bit of the exchange in some of my work I
defend a liberal position about early
abortion so I defend the view that
there's nothing morally bad about
portion so a lot of people think well
it's permissible to have an abortion but
something bad happens when the fetus
does and I think if the fetus hasn't
ever been conscious but hasn't ever had
any experiences and we aborted at that
stage but actually nothing morally bad
happens and this view might seem
unattractive because it might seem that
it's active old attitude towards all
early fetuses but what I think is that
actually among early fetuses there are
two very different kinds of beings so
James when you were in early fetus and
Elliott Lee you were in early Peter all
of us I think that we already did have
moral status then but we had washed out
us in virtue of our future in future of
the fact that we were the beginning
stages of Persons but some early fetuses
will die in or early in pregnancy either
due to abortion or miscarriage and in my
view that's a very different kind of
entity that's something that doesn't
have a future as a person and it doesn't
have moral status okay and james
franco's can't you only judge that in
hindsight when James Franco is wrecking
you on abortion and your professor at
Princeton you should lose your job okay
like that is the worst argument in favor
of early-stage abortion I've ever heard
the less when they make the argument for
early stage abortion what they say is
that this is not a fully formed human
life like that's actually an argument
okay that it has not reached the stage
of life at which we care it's not a good
argument right now an argument I agree
with because potential life is still
potential life and no question as to
what level of potential life is
necessary in order for you not to be
able to kill it that's that's a pretty
dicey question morally because they're
children who are born with disabilities
you get to kill them because they don't
have a lot of potential to grow into
full human beings or fully functional
human beings it's you know this is why
the abortion argument doesn't work but
the argument she's making is so
nonsensical the James Franco absolutely
wrecks are unconsciously like in without
even thinking about he says if a woman
decides to have an abortion with an
early fetus just that actor that
intention negates the moral statuses
that early fetus just because if she
goes out and has an abortion
it's pretty certain it's not going to
become a person and this professor just
struggles and struggles and struggles
and struggles as well she should again
this lady this lady was a she's a member
of
of the shit's and philosophy a PhD in
philosophy from MIT a bachelor's from
Harvard her father was a member of the
Princeton philosophy department faculty
she's part of the Princeton philosophy
department faculty and she teaches
courses called designing like the ethics
of creation and its control and morality
in the face of moral ignorance ok this
lady should not be able to teach a
course called morality in the face of
moral ignorance when James Franco again
James Franco a guy who looks like he
maybe has seven brain cells that he can
rub together is wrecking her
unconsciously on abortion like when even
Jim's friend is like uh this doesn't
make a lot of sense to me because it
makes no sense
Wow Wow so well done Princeton hiring
only the bus okay time for a couple of
things that I hate okay so the first
thing that I hate Skip Bayless who is
made of living saying inane things on
sports channels for a long time he used
to be on ESPN now he's on Fox Sports 1 I
believe and and he says that Colin
Kaepernick not getting a job is a
full-on disgrace
black players black players should
boycott games in the NFL
we have Colin Kaepernick a terrible
quarterback does not get a job would you
an easy cop-out that was easy talk about
to say it's because of the flag and it's
not because the subject that he is
protesting makes you uncomfortable but
you know what guess what they used to do
skills the NFL used to charge the
military to have the servicemen walk out
on the Terrible it wasn't until they got
the whistle guy got uncovered that they
were charging that they gave the money
back
no they really love the military but if
you and what I feel say one last thing
if the black players would unite and say
we will not play game one this year I
promise you it would have impact you get
so and run for something else give one
earth honor of character earth
shattering just earth chatter will be
unbelievable it'll be huge it'll be
incredible back there no ok no that's
not correct ok the fact is all that will
happen is that people will stop actually
going to games because people will
assume that we are now going to use the
NFL as a cram down for leftist politics
viewership dropped relatively
dramatically last year thanks in large
part to
colin kaepernick and other players
protesting the national anthem you do
this for colin kaepernick and you
reinvigorate this particular debate I
promise you the NFL is going to lose
ratings as well it should because when I
watch sports I don't want to hear about
how America is racist and sexist and
bigoted and homophobic I just want to
watch sports particularly when a lot of
the best players in the sport are black
I mean just enough is enough but there
is a leftist pander pandering element
that is really going over the top okay
other things that I hate to Bernie
Sanders kind of commercial and this just
demonstrates how far left the the left
of the left wing is moved Bernie Sanders
cut a commercial about Medicare for all
look who he is using as a sort of moral
guideposts in discussing Medicare for
all three the only one leaving having
any people single payer insurance
Medicare for all the time the Canadians
have become the more civilized democracy
on the planet has I would make sure that
employers general response if it out
there what that would do is free people
up to have more mobility in terms of
changing jobs in terms of not worrying
about Milnes putting them into
bankruptcy and all those types of
situations that we're in now and the
only way to do that is through a
single-payer principle congratulate
thank you I want to see is an election
year in Banaras USS a lot zingaran
Arcade Fire here taking care of people
so we're talking about celebrity stuff
not politics congratulations on your MVP
are we now at the point where the
country does need to think about some
sort of single-payer system with my
limited knowledge Warren Buffett okay so
it's like this group of deplorable
who have decided that single-payer is
just grand and great
do any of these people actually use
single-payer of course not
all of these people are extraordinarily
wealthy all of them pay for their own
insurance all of them have top-notch
insurance a single-payer health care
this idea Medicare for all okay there
have been studies that have been done
that show that on 16 out of 40 health
measurement Medicare provides less than
two-thirds of the people on Medicare
with satisfactory results on 16 out of
40 measures Medicare is wildly expensive
it has blown out the budget of the
federal government's for tremendous
extent is going to continue to blow out
the budget on to a tremendous extent
doctors are overburdened there
not taking a lot of Medicare patients
they won't take new Medicare patients
even the idea that you're gonna purchase
supplementary insurance and that's only
going to last if they're doctors who
take the supplementary insurance plus
the Medicare and a lot of doctors are
saying I'm not even to work in the
Medicare system because the
reimbursement rates are too low so no
none of this makes any sense but it just
demonstrates the the coalition of the
far left is is growing but it's still
reliant on these tent poles of insanity
people like Bernie Sanders okay so now I
want to talk about the big idea I want
to talk about this last week a little
bit and we ran out of time on it but
there's this idea that you see sometimes
discussed in philosophical circles
Athens versus Jerusalem the idea that
Western civilization is built on these
twin poles Athens in Jerusalem Athens
being the idea of Greek reason people
like Plato and Aristotle and Socrates
so sorry princess pride but and
then the other pole would be Jerusalem
and that pole being the idea of faith so
faith and reason are the twin pillars of
American society what you're watching
right now in action it's really
fascinating is that if one of those
poles falls both of the poles fall okay
if reason false then religion can't last
on its own and if religion Falls then
reason can't last on its own we now live
in a secular society where Jerusalem has
largely fallen where people have decided
that faith in a Creator who cares about
you cares what you do morally and has
created a rational system capable of our
interpretation because we're human
beings made in His image as that pole
has fallen in esteem in American circles
and in secular circles then science is
the next thing to fall because without
the idea of a rational universe and a
rational creator an irrationally
articulable system and a people who are
capable of grasping huge swathes of that
system you end up with people basically
saying that science should no longer be
a thing so slate has an article out
today talking about how science is bad
right science is actively bad because it
creates this idea that science is going
to govern all of us and that their
objective standards right and wrong or
more importantly objective standards of
true and false science can't tell you
right and wrong the time should be able
to tell you true and false in scientific
terms the left is saying science can't
even do that anymore science can't even
do that because we live in a universe
where cause and effect aren't really
things they're just things that we
perceive to be that science is all about
the idea
Topsy's being verified but those
hypotheses depend on the on the ideas
that come out of biased brains as
there's no way to really get to a
scientific truth and so you're seeing
the left do this because the left is
looking at science and they're saying
science is coming up with results that
we don't like so science itself should
be undermined without the faith and
rational creator in a rational universe
capable of our penetration it's very
difficult to make the case that science
ought to be the gold standard in terms
of how we live beyond that religion
creates the notion of free will and
personal responsibility how do you build
a society along those lines on
scientific lines if you don't believe in
any of those things
the tragedy of Western civilization is
that if you look back at Aristotle
Aristotle and Plato we're attempting to
grasp at the infinite right when they
talk about Plato's cave this idea that
that we are all sitting in a cave and we
see shadows on the wall but there's
something out there that we can't fully
grasp but we can sort of grasp the
shadows but we're grasping in darkness
you know that idea brought to fruition
by Aristotle in the idea of the forms
there's a reason that religion when when
Aristotle's work was rediscovered in the
in the late in the late first millenium
it was it was taken in by a lot of
Christian scholars like Thomas Aquinas
and merged with religion in Judaism
Maimonides tried to do the same thing
look at Aristotle and saw a religious
thinker a secular about religious think
or a rational thinker who is attempting
to reach out to the idea of the infinite
what is it about the universe that
allows us to grasp it in so much of its
complexity but not grasp its purposes
why is that there right this is a big
question that animates all of human life
and all of human reason and the striving
and the religious community takes that
question and they say okay here's our
answer to the why but science is going
to have to tell you the what we're going
to have to use reason to grasp God but
it's important to grasp God why because
God is involved in your life cares about
you wants things to be to be wants you
to succeed wants you to make the
decisions God but God is offering you a
directionality to history right you have
a messianic future that we can all move
toward right that's something that
judeo-christian religion very strongly
believes in and free will right we are
not determined by the Stars which was
sort of an ancient idea that the stars
determine our fate right we are
determined by our own capacity to make
decisions in the world you combine that
with the power of human reason and you
end up creating the most glorious
civilization in the history of
and kind but over time science religion
and now a sort of bizarre spiritualism
is eating science because people still
have the desire to grasp out at the
infinite and they're looking at science
and saying you're not getting me there
and so basically the enlightenment comes
out of these twin polls enlightenment
comes out of the idea that there's a
faith-based there's a faith-based
universe out there that we can attempt
to grasp using Aristotelian reason and
using science and this result in the
idea of natural rights right natural
right to see God based system we can
create a rational reasonable freedom
based system but only if we believe that
there is a God who made us in His image
and these were the twin poles of the
Enlightenment and then science says you
know what let's apply the standards of
science to religion ok religion is
unverifiable therefore we can't say
anything about it and then science gets
even more science gets even more
provocative science has not only can't
we prove religion religion is false
right the Richard Dawkins school of
thought science can prove religion false
and by proving religion false by proving
that it's just a figment of your
imagination we can move into a better
world right where man is king accept it
the next thing that happened is that
science ate the idea that man is king
because the more you move into the
scientific world the more you realize
that human beings are just another
animal with a bunch of brain functions
and that you know in the EO Wilson view
of sociobiology that all of our actions
are not free willed right we can't will
our own actions everything is
predetermined so why should there be
punishment Why should there be societies
why are moral standards better why
shouldn't I do whatever is hedonistic
aliy pleasurable to me why shouldn't I
be the marquis de sade
alright so science as it progressed ate
the foundations of science itself and
that's what we're seeing we're seeing
the the Ober the over us the the snake
that eats its own tail that's what's
happening with science right now because
once you disconnect science from faith
in a rational universe of the rational
Creator who cares about us then you lose
number one the impetus to to actually
seek out the universe number two
you lose the faith that there is a
rational universe to be comprehended and
number three you lose the free will that
would drive you to do all of these
things that's why you need both Athens
and Jerusalem and they seem mutually
exclusive and they do battle with each
other for primacy and the upper hand but
if you lose either one of those if you
lose science then religion just becomes
you know grasping at shadows religion
just becomes faith-based in nothing and
if you and and if you lose religion then
science just becomes a group of animals
seeking to build huts of sticks with no
meaning and no drive toward a better
society you have to answer the question
as to why a more moral society is
necessary when morality has no meaning
better has no meaning and society has no
meaning outside of just a bunch of
animals living in a similar space so
this is why you need both Athens and
Jerusalem this is why reason and faith
must hold hands even though they
disagree all the time and slap at each
other with their free hands okay so
we'll be back here tomorrow with the
mailbag it's Thursday right yes okay so
we will be after tomorrow with the
mailbag remember we are the number two
podcast on iTunes if you help us out
with subscriptions and reviews and and
listening to the show then we will
overtake Oprah we will I have faith we
will overtake Oprah and you won't get a
car and you won't get a car a note we'll
get a car get yourself a damn car okay I
don't have to go car I'm Ben Shapiro
this is a Ben Shapiro show
[Music]